the kardashian-jenner crew fly to Cloe
side but will she stay with Tristan as
Kanye West returns to Twitter with a
touching message for her ex Lamar Plus
we're clearing up beyonce nail gait hey
how's it going today you guys thanks for
checking out the daily denne which I'll
admit has felt like the daily Kardashian
or daily Beyonce but I can't help it we
have so much tea for you and we are
learning more about Khloe Kardashian and
Tristan Thompson as the couple settle
into their days as new parents to their
baby girl true et has learned that while
mom Kris Jenner has stayed by Khloe's
side since she gave birth last week a
source tells et Khloe sisters Kim
Kourtney and Kendall flew to Ohio to
visit the new mom and their newest niece
we've since learned they left but Khloe
is staying put for now in Ohio
that's for Khloe and Tristan's
relationship a source tells us the proud
parents are keeping the peace for the
sake of that baby girl of theirs quote
there are both 100% committed to moving
past the alleged cheating scandal and
focusing on the overwhelming joy they
have in their life right now with their
new daughter meanwhile another source
tells ET that Khloe is actually very
torn on what to do that she loves him
deeply book feels blindsided our source
adds she and Tristan have hardly talked
though because she is furious with him
but that her main focus is being a
mother still some friends and family
feel betrayed by Tristan and cannot
trust him and I don't blame them I'm not
alone there either because Modern
Family's Sarah Hyland went on a Tristan
bashing on social media Annie T's Kelsey
Knight talked to her just last night
about how she really thought about the
drama what I love the most about
following you on social media is how he
did you get on things and I saw your
heat for Khloe Kardashian it was it's a
personal thing it's like she took to
your heart I also like don't know how
that became like such a big things I
thought everybody was hating on
like everybody was but it's because I
say like Tristan face and everyone's
like crazy this is newsworthy but I'm
felt like in Mean Girls was like who
else has been personally victimized by
Tristan Thompson me um I just I I just
love them up my females
I love my females and I think she's
amazing and I hope she's happy in
whatever decision she makes amen Sarah
you see everyone's got an opinion on
this and I tend to side with her except
she went Mean Girls and I went Elle
Woods and Legally Blonde like eating
chocolates in my bed screaming at my
soap liar
but I'm respecting Chloe for fighting
for her family meanwhile Chloe's
ex-husband Lamar Odom got a surprising
shoutout from none other than Kim's
hubby Kanye West ez returned to Twitter
on Sunday with this really heartfelt
memory of Lamar you'll remember the
former NBA pro was hospitalized after he
was found unconscious in a Nevada
brothel while Kanye tweeted this pic of
the Bros my favorite part of walking
into MSG to play st. Pablo I used to go
to the hospital and play Lamar the album
when he was learning to walk and talk
again then we walked into the arena
together
well the bromance continued with Lamar's
response yesterday he tweeted glad I
could be there for you bro like you came
through for me it was a big state to be
on after everything I went through but
it was worth it last week a source will
ET Lamar genuinely feels bad about
hearing about Tristan stepping out on
Khloe but I would love to hear what
Kanye thinks about it someone give that
man a stage because I need a Tristan
Rance which by the way the same man who
reminded Taylor Swift and all of us that
Beyonce had the best video of all time
has yet to say anything about her
show-stopping set at Coachella I do
wonder if he was one of the four hundred
and fifty eight thousand global viewers
who watched that's the number of people
YouTube says watch to be on Saturday
making her performance the most viewed
performance at the festival ever to say
all eyes were on B is an understatement
because the Beehive with those hot guys
of theirs seemed to notice one tiny
detail that Beyonce
only changed costumes during the show
she also changed a friggin nail color
mid-performance
you'll notice at the beginning of her
performance her nails are black and
later in the show they are seemingly
silver fans were undoubtedly shook by
this tweeting stuff like we don't
deserve her and that is the level of
extra we all need to achieve if I'm
being honest even I was trying to figure
out how she pulled off this Witchcraft
and Wizardry that is until I noticed
that those photos Beyonce posted on her
website
while they appear to be from a dress
rehearsal folks check this shot out
she's got silver nails but notice there
is no crowd no screaming fans it's empty
that was on her Instagram and when you
compare this photo Getty Images took
with a similar one Beyonce posted
wearing the same outfit her nails are
different now the rehearsal pics also
explained how B got those photos up so
fast on her Instagram page that night so
B honestly did not appear to switch up
her man you guys but she's still our
queen and the greatest living performer
of all time
Kanye was right all right we'll see what
the new cycle brings tomorrow I'm all
Beyonce tau okay so until then share
this video with your friends you can
also head over to eat C online.com for
more on all of this and I'll see you
guys tomorrow
[Music]